Hi,
this is an invitation to Dutch citizens
and their leaders alike.
I'm coming to Holland next week for two
reasons,
apart from the fact that I love Holland
and I'm always looking for an excuse to
go there.
First on January 17th from 10:00 AM to
7:30 PM.
I'm going to talk to corporate and other
organizational leaders in Amsterdam in a
session entitled envisioning the future
at the warehouse by wicked grounds in
Amsterdam.
Details of the session can be found in
the description of this video as can
information about tickets which are
still available.
I'm going to begin the day with a
lecture on the psychology of motivation
and emotion.
I want to discuss deeply from the
symbolic level all the way down to the
level of of neuroscience,
how it is that vision and motivation and
the regulation of emotion or deeply
entwined in that the vision that we set
for ourselves defines the framework
within which we operate in the world,
perceive the world and react emotionally
to the world.
I want to help everyone who comes to the
session understand exactly what that
means in the most modern and uptodate
psychological manner possible,
and so all lecture for about 90 minutes
about that,
perhaps a bit longer after that,
participants will have the opportunity
to complete the future authoring program
or at least to begin the future
authoring program,
which is an online reading program that
I designed with my colleagues that
enables people to deeply conceptualize
their lives three to five years down the
road and to make a plan,
let's say,
to maximize the quality of their life.
You began the future authoring program
which is available publicly by the way,
at cell faltering Dotcom.
You begin the future authoring program
by considering the most important
dimensions of your life,
family,
friends,
intimate relationships,
ambitions for the future from an
economic perspective,
use of time outside of work and the
regulation of temptations like drug and
alcohol use,
and imagine yourself three to five years
down the road.
If you are living the life that would be
optimal for you most meaningful and
productive life.
Then you're asked to contemplate each of
those dimensions to decide how you would
optimize your life,
specifically along those dimensions,
then to write for 15 minutes about what
your life could be like in three to five
years if you were really taking care of
yourself like someone that you cared
for.
Then to write for 20 minutes about what
your life would be like if your bad
habits and and inadequacies and
characterological flaws,
got the upper hand and lead you into the
ground.
Then to write out a detailed plan for
the attainment of your goals,
your the,
the realization of your vision,
including writing about why it would be
good for you to undertake this
adventure,
let's say,
and also why it would be good for your
family and the broader community,
so to fully articulate a plan that will
comprise the contents of that day.
Details about the event can be found in
the description of this video as well as
a timeline for the day and information
about where you can pick,
pick up tickets which are still
available.
The second event on January 19th is
hosted by a Dutch organization.
Netherland.
Say Leo,
they've organized what they hope will be
the beginning of a serious national
conversation about Dutch and European
identity as well as immigration policy.
I'm going to begin the event which will
involve 2000 people and the number of
well known speakers from a variety of
backgrounds.
I'll start with a 45 minute discussion
on the psychology of identity and
concentrate more specifically on on
Europe.
Where are we in Europe?
Broadly speaking,
how did we get here?
What have we done right and wrong?
Where are we going and why and how
should each of us conduct ourselves so
we get there.
How should each of us conduct ourselves
so that are stable and productive?
Society state,
stable,
productive and free,
and don't fall prey to the temptations
of radicalism either on the left or the
right.
I hope to initiate a process of deep
thought during this meeting,
the organizer.
So we're hoping to generate 25
recommendations as a consequence of this
meeting for the future of Dutch and I
suppose more broadly European and
Western society and there are still some
tickets available to this event.
So I'll also provide the information
about that in the description of this
video.
So thank you very much.
I hope to see you there if you're
interested,
and
that's all I have to say about that.
Bye Bye.